foreign
[Music]
Russian territory which will be the
informal annexation of those territories
and then the big change is that
Russia will regard any hostilities that
are going on in these regions as an
attack on Commercial territory
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
message to Ukraine and it is a message
to the West that Russia is stepping up
escalation and this is the point whereby
the Russian defense Victory kicks in and
visitors the use of nuclear weapons in
particular so it's a dangerous
escalation on the apartment
was accompanied by an increase in a
nuclear threats to to the Western to
afraid all of this should be taken
seriously
[Music]